Brian what is the craziest story of
frequent flyer miles that you have
you've heard a lot I'm sure yeah i mean
my personal experience so the crown
jewel of airlines is emirates you know
they've got beautiful planes they
actually have a shower in their first
class cabin so just last week I was able
to fly them for $90 in first class and
of course some frequent flyer dollars to
fly a ten-thousand-dollar ticket yeah so
they're now transfer partners of
American Express you can transfer points
there but you can also they're also
partners with Alaska Airlines and even
if you have no miles or points Alaska
Airlines allows you to buy miles
whenever you book a ticket at a pretty
cheap rate so you can essentially by
emirates first class i flew from India
to to New York via Dubai and it came out
to a 1,700 bucks for my friend who flew
along with me for that
ten-thousand-dollar see the shower the
funny thing is I took my shower right
after takeoff and the captain actually
turned on the seat belt sign and
frantically told the flight attendants
it down as I'm in the shower it starts
bumping around so I had to run out I
left my watch in warm a shoe to my to I
actually posted a video on how he got
out of the shower how he got back to me
too much information I did not go hi
friend I robux people who did / but
actually Mumbai actually Dubai and
Mumbai for 90 bucks and some points
transferred from American Express how
long did it take for you to figure this
out um you know it takes a little bit of
research but that's the beautiful thing
about miles and points it's difficult
for the masses but if you want to
educate yourself there are so many
incredible values out there to the
holidays yeah this is bright Robert
captain with me from HBS you got a
parachute this guy in five hours into
cambridge to lecture all the smart kids
oh yeah we companies you know we were
talking finally for the first time in
many years the airlines business is
booming and so while they like these
points programs they're not as critical
as they were and so they're there
they're trying to small these these
programs down a little bit should a
corporation keep the frequent flyer
miles of their employees or should we
continue the trend where I get my miles
that's I don't probably it's never going
to change it's too late to change I know
what it's like the road warriors keep
their miles
yeah and enough time away from home
throw a little bones look here's why
otherwise why would you want that to
happen it's like a third rail where
Brian Kelly Quinn last question very
quickly here what the best use of your
miles is it for seat upgrades is it for
magnitude Christian upgrades used to be
valuable but now there are so many
co-pays you know it could be up to five
hundred dollars in cash copay can make
sense but I still like the good old
award Redemption international business
or first class you know frequent flyer
programs like United I go to the
Maldives for twenty-four dollars oh
you're killing me Brian go away Brian
Kelly with this the points guy I'm going
on the site you should too